all right hello everyone oh that's a
little close how are you guys all doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we're here with another video
so this is Noob with a mill episode
number 17 and as you guys can see last
episode went ahead and got myself a
kraken up to two pets now do I deserve
them probably not um Kraken 50k SE then
I think was 70 so we've gotten a little
too lucky at this point but what I'm
going to go ahead and do to start off
this video is kind of show you guys what
I got going on uh My overall Bank value
is 214 mil but as you guys can see here
we have two thir age plate legs that are
merching off for 700k margin hopefully
which would give us 1.4 mil but we'll
see in due time with that said going to
go ahead and start up my trolls task
should be pretty AFK and pretty chill
finished up the task of trolls so we are
done with that uh another task 15 okay
nice and easy nice and easy task so 43
iron dragons I'll do it can't catch mag
Pi rip 7 Hunter iron Dragon done irons
iron dragons done blood Felts not too
bad do that in the catacombs um I
usually Canon them actually should I
Canon them I don't I never know what to
do for these all right been working on
some econ stuff but finish that off so
we got aberant specs I think I actually
have to go to the Slayer tower now for
that which is a little disappointing but
it is what it is finish off my aberant
Specter task uh did them in the
catacombs and that was a really long
task I did not imagine that but I guess
we got some limper Roots that's decent
amount of blood felds we'll go ahead and
do those again in here and LP wordss
have crashed a ton finished off our
blood feld's task time for another one
and Cal fights man I wish I could do KQ
I really do but I can't finish off Cal
fights um really nothing much going on
here Bob back some gear so I can go
ahead and do some Slayer and assignment
128 black demons I mean it is what it is
I'm fine with it I was hoping we get a
boss task but it's fine that is kind of
what I wanted to see I wish we would
have gotten that tonight but I guess
I'll start off tomorrow morning uh
probably watching the Spurs game against
Arsenal with a little bit of kbd and
there we go went ahead and finish off my
kbd task so that was a good 45 kills or
so brings us up to 375 KC time to get
another task maybe boss task 89 Anu
we'll take it I think they are still in
ne's cave so lucky me and another task
done went ahead and did those in the
catacombs and I don't know I don't know
how common this is this may be worth
like taking off something else and
putting this on my block list but um I
think I'm gonna have to go ahead and
cancel that so more Cal fights not
terrible and just like that 89 Slayer
man we are moving on up I think we I
mean 90 is kind of cool but dark beasts
aren't that great working on 91 um got
four kills left in the task and we're on
to some more hopefully something decent
and like as soon as I stopped recording
that of course you finished the task
black demons nice and AFK could do that
while I do a little bit of homework
and nice and easy another
task boom Cal fight God bro I just keep
getting non-stop cow fights but yeah
777k away from 98 or 99 strength and uh
yeah long ways from 90 Slayer and last
task I'll be doing for a little bit
so iron dragons we'll take it whatever
do it later and time for another
task there we go nice and easy actually
actually managed to get myself an
ancient sh always welcome um hell hounds
you know same thing just going AFK hell
hounds task is over going to actually do
a clue scroll for the first time in a
while I had a hard one that I had in my
bank that I planned on doing once I got
the requirements I never got the
requirements so yeah but we got
ourselves some dagaut I think I'm going
to AF cam I would do dad Kings but I
still exam time so got some homework and
[__] to do first time I've done a hard
clue in a while so uh yeah don't expect
much oh god well I mean it's over
100k and finished up the dagaut Tas so
got ourselves a medium clue but on top
of that 44 black dragons will I be doing
kbd oh I don't know maybe I'll probably
bring myself to do it I'm a baller there
we go 92 magic not too bad another two
levels then we'll get started with some
pking content and now for a little bit
of postom first one of the episode go
ahead and finish off a medium clue um
obviously not getting much from that um
if I would have it would have been live
com but there we go finished up another
I think kbd task which is pretty
impressive I ended up getting gargoyles
while gargoyles are pretty profitable I
hate them just because for afking them
they take so long and so luckily enough
I got another AFK task and here you guys
can see I got 89 range then in the next
clip went ahead and got 93 HP not too
bad black demon task is done got to go
ahead and do a hard clue here in a
second though hopefully we can finish it
off and there we go got ourselves a Jad
task I'll probably go ahead and do some
AFK Mage real quick quick cuz still have
a little bit of eon to do but at some
point I'll get back to that but going to
go ahead do a hard clue right now and
then we'll go on and do some strange
jewelry guys we're getting ever closer
to 94 Mage and another hard
clue Jesus and another Jad killed so no
pet off the bat sad times however
obviously Oh wrong guy uh 3 1 I'm not
lucky hey at least he's straight up with
me you know and time for another task
hopefully something AFK so I can finish
off this econ and I mean that's going to
be like a 10-minute task so all right
finally closing in I'm being done with
my homework so if we could go ahead and
get ourselves a boss task that would be
great exams are almost done it's a hell
of a time to be alive boys uh please
okay well nowhere near as I was saying
let's go ahead and get ourselves boss
task and now for a little bit of postc
com so I know I know I've been compl
complaining complaining complaining
about not getting any boss task then I
get some dks you think I'd be pretty
hyped but I end up canceling them for
obvious reasons considering I can only
kill 35 while if I got a dag task I'd be
able to kill them all but there we go
got a sire task I end up going and doing
the Tai boyana Quest or whatever to
unlock the Hosta and then from there go
ahead and show off a couple inventories
of loot I end up doing like 60 kills but
I don't have all of the loot from all
those but with that said let's get back
into live comom all right so there we go
went ahead and finished off our Abyssal
demons task I ended up doing about 60
kills at sire and then I was streaming
and just got hella pissed because I kept
dying so we figure that's done for now
um I don't know I'll come back to it
eventually just because it'll be decent
but my defense is really low my attack's
really low so the kills are a little
rough but let's go ahead and get
ourselves another task so 220 neck reels
nice little bursting T should be pretty
easy um Mage is getting up there should
be able to get like 100k XP or something
like that so not bad at all going to go
ahead and do a hard clue that I went
ahead and got while I was on my Abyssal
demons task and yeah and there we go
hard clue done that was a lot longer
than it should have been but there we
go under 10k is what it is I don't know
what I expected all right so I went
ahead and did a little bit of nightmare
zone I'm working on 75 defense just so I
can use a Den's bull work to go ahead
and make my uh I don't know I mean 75
defense is all around just a good thing
to have there's a lot of items that I'd
eventually need to unlock with that but
on a uh on a bigger note we got
ourselves an imbued Berserker ring so
this is the first imbued ring we have I
don't know I haven't just I haven't done
a whole lot of nightmare Zone on this
account and realistically I have to
start imbuing all my rings just so that
I can always like have just the sickest
drinks so there's the first one um right
now I'm going to go ahead and make a
video on me killing
um skzo I have I don't know how many
totems I have right now there's just
like weird ass thing in my lip but I'm
too too Focus so we have 16 totems we'll
probably have 17 18 after I get a couple
totem pieces I think from scoo so yeah
we're going to go ahead get those loots
if you guys have already seen that video
then this might not be all that useful
like the next minute or two but I'll
keep those loots in here too and here we
go so here I am as you can see a lot of
people here doing it nothing too bad as
far as gear goes basically I think just
kind of your normal thing I don't know I
mean from what I'm seeing other people
wearing it looks pretty similar but I've
never killed scoto though so
it is going to be a little bit of
something I don't know I I know I'm
risking everything I have terrifying
stuff I know yes I know items will be
dropped on death so what items would I
lose probably nothing nothing too much
let's go ahead and do this I don't know
how this is going to go but hopefully I
don't use that much food because I have
three [__] totems on me okay got to
pray Mage all right here comes the first
loot that kill was actually really
annoying I've never killed this thing
before I'm not going to waste charges on
these stupid ass spawns but I've never
killed this thing before and just
running around the outside just made me
hate my life all right so we got some
angler fish first hard clue ancient
Shard obviously I'm not going to be
doing the hard Clues I thought about it
but as I said earlier I don't have other
requirements so it is what it is um yeah
let's keep going this kill was so much
cleaner and just easier than the last
kill the last kill is honestly probably
three times as long this one I just
[__] [__] up I'm also trying to buy
time until I hit this [__] 16 but
apparently that's just not going to
happen and here we go loot number two so
not was my charges again why is this
death animation so
long and ancient
Shard why did I say it like that ancient
Shard got some torsal death runes 500
actually not that bad I am going to make
a decent amount of money off this it
looks like but okay kill number four oh
40 onx bolt tips oh damn man I at least
want the claw I at least want the claw I
don't have my hopes up for anything else
two ancient sh card is pretty chill but
I just I want the claw so bad man number
six on the board give me the claw no
claw 500 more death run though this oh
okay death animation wasn't what I
thought it would be 10 uncut Dragon
Stones though kill number eight uh I
think from what I was seeing the drop
rate of the claws one and 25 and the
drop rate of the pets 1 and 66 from what
the wiki is saying I don't know if
that's necessarily true um I Heard
speculation before this all began that
pet rate would be one in 100 so I don't
know kill number nine incoming please
just give me the
claw
numero
uh I don't know I don't know how you say
nine and there is kill number 11 so
probably nothing yeah nothing another
kill done I think this is kill number
like 12 something like that we're
getting we're getting up there in the KC
ancient Shard room bar is actually I
mean this thing has so good of drops it
kind of sucks that realistically this is
a ton of time that I've spent getting
these totems whenever I'm using them
feels really good there we go down with
another kill 14 and onx bolts I mean
we'll take them we'll take them add them
to the collection if you guys haven't
seen I don't know yeah I ended up buying
5,000 onx bolts because they went down
like 150 GP and I mean realistically
after this initial update of this goo
thing he's going to be getting killed as
much as he was previous so doesn't
really matter price will go back up
hopefully we get something I don't know
I don't have a lot of Hope for this
episode at this point and here we go
last kill on the new so I'm a little
depressed I really wanted the claw or
the pet or any of them but at this point
yeah the dream's dead well I uh I missed
the level as I usually do but there is
75 defense so the reason that we went
ahead and did that was because I had to
do a couple things like like I want to
wear a DFS for certain things like kbd
and whatnot and also on top of that
really really want to go ahead and
unlock the Den's bull work which I just
did um makes just bursting so much
easier but yeah there we go got from 92
to 95 I believe and now I'm just going
to go ahead use up the rest of the
points I'll be getting definitely closer
99 strength also maybe in bu ring and so
now we end the video so going to go
ahead show you guys what I usually show
you so as far as stats go basically up
to 1561 not too bad closing in ever so
closely to 99 strength I want to go
ahead and save that for Sunday you guys
will probably be watching this on Sunday
I want to save that to go ahead and get
that on a friend since it's typical that
we get 99s on each other it's just kind
of a cool thing that we do and it's
pretty late right now so I figure I'll
get that out tomorrow um and yeah I mean
other than that let's go ahead and look
at the bank value now so we'll zoom out
a little bit I do want you guys to keep
in mind that I do actually have three
mil over here in the grand exchange and
Slayer enchantments have gone down to 7K
each which is a little depressing but uh
I wasn't bedding in them going up right
now it was more so of an impending like
change to them so let's go ahead Bank
everything and now I'm going to pull in
the price evaluator onto the screen cool
little thing conduit has that OS buy
doesn't not a sponsor by any means but
just shouting him out for doing the cool
things they do you know all right so now
go over to bank value calculate
and okay this is taking a lot longer
than I thought it would so right now we
have 206 mil add the three that I got in
the bank or in the GE that adds up to
209 I think we've gone down a little bit
in this video but honestly we are
progressing the account like no other we
are getting there we're starting to
unlock some really cool things with
Slayer up to 89 um once I start liking s
a little more it'll be pretty chill um
but yeah that'll be it for this video so
hopefully you guys enjoyed if you guys
did make sure to leave a like uh feel
free to hit up my clan chat ingame large
exp lamp um also comment anything down
below you guys want to tell me subscribe
to the channel if you really enjoy the
content and uh yeah with that said hope
you guys have a wonderful day and
[Music]
peace